they all have the same problem no matter
who you are, no matter what name, no matter
moritz, blah, or who
doesn't matter, elias m'barek, they all
face the same challenge, they
want a rolex or a patek and
the classic retailer says
jos is good, but i have it  don't stop or the
delivery time is five years and that's where
I come into play for me there are no
limits the whole beauty of social
media how you can go from a
watch seller in
cologne to the luxury influenza of the superstars
within a few months a crazy story
that makes it  only social media possible and
the best case for that is colleague
gebauer that's why listen to how it goes
straight into the conversation with marc
gebauer home how's it going for the
insert yes thanks for coming up so
that's really unsurpassed so
you have to take a look at it too  is
healthier than a video to be seen on youtube
are anyway also from instagram with me
so but mi  t tie and
handkerchief in the colors of ours is
so enthusiastic is about it it
has always been like that you
actually have been every day since i was around 20
and would then pay attention
to where you come from you come did you graduate high school or not or
during my vocational training  my high
school diploma in such a school education
that was my first steps and
then i studied media communication and
journalism that was
nothing at all besides i always worked
for a men’s outfitter in cologne
that was
and besides so if there was a
bonus now or  so i always put all the
money i
ever earned in my ears and that's how
the love for the suits came about because of
the classic men's outfitters where i
looked after the online shop and on the
other hand for the watches, that's how
it all came about  if we had actually been there
from the start yes absolutely i
had to decide after
my studies e  either i will now follow my
professional career like it usually
is a family also in the
fashion industry which you think is a bit more
corporate volt or i
stay in the luxury segment and then i was given the opportunity
to set up an online shop there
i  had such a budget have
the highest location is all higher
in cologne it’s true that that’s not we in
cologne probably already well well they
have very well-chosen classic
conservative Italian men’s fashion
you were expensive so to speak
probably that sonja was already
advising a customer there  have or hardly any people and
that wouldn't studies good step
and he has that was right at the very
beginning when I was 18 or something like that no but
then when I was 20 I actually worked
more on the pc and just
sell things online it  it's a
bit like my theresa as well
as theresa now
publicly listed companies from
a  m munich he was like
that at the time
you couldn't imagine that three suits could be
bought online for 4000 euros
because you always
have to adjust your suit but because
the brands aren't available
everywhere  we also
sold very well to russia, for example, and if
you're a fan of it, you
didn't have the opportunity at the time
to buy it online outside of us
and that's how the twist came we
know today how are you now 33
today  not so long ago and
then it started touring bought
because you collected that just nice what yes i
had my well man yes i got
that was a a groundbreaking as well as
10,000 euros and these 10,000
euros i bought him a jaeger lecoultre
reverso invested in gold it costs 10
1010 and now you can imagine
and of course my parents
didn't like it at all
you can only do that  spend it so
i don't put my jokes aside
it was never my strength so a
classic deposit or saving or
that i never had a connection to
and i did that and
then the second year then there was a tea
master pepsi die  even today you still know
what the urls values are for 4500 euros
so in particular this watch
is around 17,000 euros that is a fac
or for yes but that currently one i wou
d say was in the price segment at the time that was now a
normal proce
s all  others also
felt this price, so to speak,
and then it was them,
then it was the state and at some
point the possibility arose that i
could change employers and then have
to be on the road, that was to colleagues at the
time and that’s only in anderson
dealers and sales stationary
business in cologne they opened a
branch in düsseldorf and
then i only now have a
p. in cologne  I worked for a few months, you have to say,
I knew a little bit about watches,
but I didn't have an
immense
amount of specialist knowledge, I knew the models, but I didn't know what
the prices were or anything else,
but I arrived, yes, I
don't like it
and  With this change, I then
considered that I should simply explain the function of
the clocks to myself and
then I
would also record it for the viewers, and so it was the very
first video on the subject of
what is already employed by watch dealers,
exactly but a bit off the mark
I would have said yes but I had no
idea so I had to read everything about GMT
Greenwich Mean Time and stuff
like that, how do you use it now and then
?
it came across as medium but sometimes because
it was very
stuffy and then at some point after a while
de  r first influenza with him
then ignited the whole thing that should only
then together with the ballast that was the one on
the council at the time and he is a food
blogger with almost three million
followers and he made the
comparison one euro watch against 300,000 euros
that was  he was 2 what i to 18
i think it ended like that not at all
just not that long ago main kanal
math likes better the youtube channel
has only been around since 2010 so and then
we started there he came in and
just got over  we
talked about the differences and that worked quite well
and then in december 18
i went to stuttgart for the first time
and then joined the coop and
tim gabel and so the big youtube the
big youtuber formats
and the feedback from the
community was very good  and then i
just kept going and i
always tried not to get this very
opaque watch market in front of the
trade
and f  For young people there is
always a lot of interest in it but the
concessionaires are a bit
let me say concessionaires they are called the
official dealers they are mostly
a bit reserved for young people how should I say that
compared to the old-established say
I have  the money not for just yes that
you said now i didn't say now
but that was so that you
then have possible fear of
contact i noticed that at the time
when i
went somewhere so the doors heavy
doors bouncer was upset how
can i  help him yes i just wanted to
provide information he drove yes
if it was a bit strange with
us it was always easy you can
come in you can talk and the people
already have a connection to me even
if i didn't know them but knew me
she then already youtube about
youtube and then the conversation was
just easy the people could at
or kö  we still have all the questions today,
so what questions we get asked about the
sold automatic watch or anything
else that has to be asked there, the
battery is growing, so everything is possible with us,
so if there are any questions there
, I mean and and vigo is
then he can at today  youtube we have
we are shortly before 300 i think 270
or around two and has 280 somehow
around 2075 so is growing well and also on
instagram meanwhile also similar in size
exactly
the same had both big grill yes
so we are otherwise only active on
twitter what to do about that  should say is the
main channel so i'm from
germany but we
actually only do 80 percent of the content in
english so you have to say it's always
with you and such a case that fits
you thought that you're just like that in
this world  at home and then you look,
you taste, you smell about the
same as this world and that's why
the rapper and sportsman and all
kinds of people seem  hen also, so to speak,
in the target group youtube instagram who
are interested in us somehow to
end up yes they all have the same
problem no matter who you are no matter what
name no matter moritz staying true or no matter
who plays no role at all elias m'barek
everyone faces the same
challenge  you want a rolex
or a patek and the classic
retailer says fine
but i don't have it or delivery times
are five years and that's where i come
into play there are no limits for me
now just before the interview we talked about it
i know for 620 hours  in
dubai because there is no
one for me if someone says to me like i need
this watch please for a video or for
that and i need this watch
tomorrow we also pay then i sit on the
plane or someone else and
continues to bring it to me  there is
n't really one like that who's already
[laughter]
say now over the years then in the
watch shop  elle and
human marketplace for watches yes
we actually only work online so
we only have our online shop in that
sense and sell through it simply because
this is not scalable so what
we are currently doing cannot be shown in
stationary stores so
whoever likes that  don't think but because
they are very luxury products but on
his bike friday we sell well
over 100 watches in one day and our
packaging and everything you get with
it that's an overall concept
consisting of
then also in eating experience with these
nuts or popcorn what we  do everything
exclusively and you ca
n't process that stationary so
we just decided
to only work online due to corona
you always announced
that exactly yes a little independently for how many
years says since
2020 so not at all in april yes
be aware team we are currently
eleven people but yes, we are looking for a
lot of people  from time to time and how is your view
of such a crown 24 something because i
would say if you only had
it you get it too when you that
is yes then it comes is okay to try it then
the 124 for example i like
crown 24 i am  also even a user of
this platform the company will
also make an immense
profit without a doubt so
the tim stracke the founder was two
years ago in the podcast
meanwhile big project investors
in it so is a very successful
digital to say about the marketplace but
through this  this current
hype has an
immense deficit in terms of usability so for me as
an active consumer who now buys krone 24
don't know maybe
8 to 30 40 a month or let's
say I try at least
to him I can only say krone 24 and  that
's also the listeners don't be
frustrated when the clocks ask and they
're just not available because
i'll give an example  I ask what
comes with me also in the history with
security in the account understand I
ask 20 watches and of these 20
watches a maximum of 23 are available a maximum
and I have to say you should
maybe headline to a system like
ebay that you there  in the
ratings or i don't know but
at the moment the usability and
working with 124 is very late but that
's the most relevant digital market
yes definitely there are 120 to the
biggest for dealers now of course there
are others so it's running with dealers
currently so that there are
whatsapp groups where a pre-selection is now
taking place the most important 250
dealers there is a group in america
there is a group in germany and
then it plays itself out there when
i actually play everything so that’s where
you actually mainly buy  and that
means in the end the watch brands that
we only put very reduced models on the
market so that dougan that is yes
be  you knew about a shortage and we're talking about the topic
now because it's so
scarce it
's ugly scarce no it
's the production can't
keep up so rolex produces 1.1 million
ears or apg produces 38,000 tours
but the demand is just too high
the watches are  put on the market
100 percent but more people are
interested than building what you can
tell the luxury boom is really a
thing, so the demand for luxury goods is higher
than ever before
in the area of cars, we can also see that
ith watches but that’s how i
is  that the watch has already become more of a
substitute currency because if
we are now talking about the fact that large
values should come to third countries, for example or here too
then a wat
ch is so I mean trie
just I don’t k
ow 500 let’s say 2004 tried over
00,000 euros now
So impossible to bring to Hong Kong
, you have to register everything, prove it and
so on, but stop by you  ese due to
this high value in a small room
is a big topic this time it will be
accurate with watches and
therefore it is more like a substitute currency
so ears is much more than a
timepiece and much more than a
luxury product we are a
business model there exactly  so i
now understand where you
come from have you been a dealer for years from the
network to the manufacturer
yourself or are you still a dealer
now
how much money do we buy
directly from the manufacturers
no no i don’t have a single case
like that but we have now  two three
relationship with also producers so
watch brands like frank müller
we have now brought out a limited series that was
also very well
received but in general is or that
instead of that the manufacturers are a
bit afraid of me making contact like this
i can only
tell everyone i'm happy to be in contact with the
manufacturers but
at the moment it is  so that we
help ourselves to private individuals or
other dealers like tobi it's strange
you might not be able to fully
understand it but the business is
going like that you now have a good
name you go to a concessionaire
you always buy and buy and  the group buys like
crazy he knows that you are a
retailer but you don't sell
publicly on platforms you then
give the goods to me and i
just use this private
retailer it's not a model it's you
know a lot of big customers from concessionaires
yes we know  then obviously there and
then they somehow want
to pass it on from the public
somehow earn money then when you get a
seal you take it all in yourself
you still believe as well as say when you
want on the gray market or something and
then you have sources where  you say
i can sell it again, on the
one hand it's what the current
collection is about  on the other hand, my
husband usb or so means my
unique selling point is definitely
models to be found on the current
market that do not fit in terms of price structure,
so if you now
go to a website then
you will not find a 57 11 nautilus in rose gold
that  currently such a hype
product just to name numbers
dio was sold two months ago for
220,000 euros then it was sold a
week ago for 500 now again at
300 such really super high
products that's not mine i
sell things that people don't  so
really on the screen there are
always trending topics where no one is
looking where you say okay the
price structure of a
toner god knows on the leather strap with
an original trimming the quantities
are much smaller or such a daytona
beach was reported for a very short time
all rolex  -watches was that if now
rolex watches and then you can
really
invest well and on the other hand know  me
too, of course, through the connection to
a lot of people what brands are possibly
planning, for example, or
apg, this is a manufacturer, we can
expect a lot, you already have
background information where you know, okay,
if you place yourself there now,
then in october you will already be one  being
able to take enormous returns and these market
dynamics that is my expertise so
if people want to invest there now
or something like that or then do it is actually
like other stocks yes explanation your
portfolio management so you have
that we do exactly if
someone wants to do something now then then  so then you know it
others knows about stocks and you
can just hear them with your ears so
we finally lose the
paper but valuables like stocks
don't make money but it's at the end of the
century and it's also
possible sometimes with that  a trade there will
have to add 50,000 euros to say there
is more hh
so usually the size  and dimensions let's
say ok basic margin now with basic
rolex models i can't reinvent the wheel now
when you
buy and then all ten percent are included
but it costs and rolex costs
10,000 euros i help sell but of
course there are other models that you
where you know the
story you know something is happening
or the topic of dials that's
always something i've preached from the beginning to
focus on special
things that means, for example, there's a
model that costs regular date without a
special 240,000 euros if you  but
now this date comes with a very
special dial which has only rarely been
built then it can
happen that this day date might
currently cost 50,000 euros but the
potential for value increase is enormous hear
and things like that i just know the
collection i know what is possible  is
and that's that i'm here i'm hunting on
that around the world are from the bet  he
and boxing so specifically
boxing i also sometimes give for a
box has
bought
a lot of box 10,000 euros at the moment sometimes not just a rolex box but
i just have to have the boxee box but the so
this box
that that that has to  so you have this
box if you have the watch without this box
then i wouldn't buy it so it
's worthless to me so you have to have
this connection, you just
have to have everything together and of
course other dealers don't
do that now who complete them  I wouldn't have that now,
but that's what I'm looking for,
I just like to put things
together, ok, and say
which brands you know best. Which brands do you
want
?  one comes after that or apg and
patek and richard mille are on
number three
that i would be
okay in order they are even more expensive or papi
i know james from lebron he is
there i think i make my
ambassador exactly he always has such
huge things but
in them there are always
price ranges other than euros yes although i have to
say that this has only just
happened so to my self-employment
for example  was a roll with a
black dial at 22,000 euros
exactly the same watch is currently on
sale at around 55,000 euros so that
means that was yes how
come is that the data p we can get into the
future of the children the more precisely we can get into it
a little bit  look at the future
also
the next question who now so why is this
happening and hurry where is the
end then there are
comparative figures from other manufacturers,
for example how you now take them into
cars so both by the way both and the
role and the nautilus both have the same
designer conductor  both designed in the 1970s
, so
we can easily deduce what else
is possible with a nautilus  it's currently
130,000 euros, you can't
transfer it directly, but i have that's
why the demand is very
high and patek produces 80,000 for the
world and from the age of 40 and then you can
see the demand is significantly
more than 40,000 people  yes, i
had just heard about a conversation
that
the two million had over two
million inquiries where and tell me
i have to ask yes and i am also
proud i have already
told the spokesman i am now we
are in a camp on the subject  if i
now
think team iwc also thinks that he so i liked it a lot
i was on site from now on i
only got it from the carrying
and also emotional if you are such a
mountain or absolutely absolutely so that
is also so passionate  people are
working again and i have to say i liked
the history of the company
because then it is clear the other
testimonials like the work tom brady
lewis hamilton is ever  not so
bad pop gave me there
certainly didn't bring me into the league but
just another other kind of maybe
partnership and I thought it was
great so I have them are also very
expensive so
how do you appreciate that a so I think
the ebc enormous  there are opportunities in the
market they have a great product line
that has remained the same for a long
time so one of my
favorite watches from the collection is
the portugieser the big pilote
i still have times when the
watch was traded on the list does
n’t even mean  that the list price
is 9,000 euros, for example, and the watch
is sold on the market for 13,000 euros,
so the demand is higher than
what is being offered for the production,
but it is still the case that when we
now dive into the real world, that is,
in the  I now live that is
not necessarily what the
concessionaire serves but that
the real market is talking about
market prices  if you now put money on the
table, then it would now be money in the
evening for the watch and it is so that
the brand has not yet
managed
to raise the demand in such a way that it is
really well received in the gray market, but
that suits me  will say that suits
me so turn the watch 100 percent no
don't get me wrong iwc as
such the dna of the brand and everything i
think it's very very good and the
handwriting they don't bend there
they always go new ways what now that too
as far as design is concerned i like that very
much
and yes but it is not in the league of
watches that are currently worldwide or in the app
store wrong word it will be like
that the league is wrong the production and
other do that is out of the question
you can do that too if  you other
manufacturers who are now probably being
smiled at a bit like hitler or
we don't have to persuade them they are all
top top from sega it doesn't matter to me either
i love it doesn't matter my heart beats au  f
shaped i like this price range everything is
top but there are
certain things from a company
political point of view in terms of quantities what odem
apg has consequences it made it and in the rpg
was previously known for it -22% always no matter
where you go minus 20 percent and had
nothing today  there is nothing at all you can
hope that simply has become scarce
they simply
shut down the sales network yes simply
says bishop hereby concessionaires and
so there is no longer we simply
do everything ourselves have the sales
structure simply managed
to take the sales network in hand
similar  as with mine i mean frank
müller is also a mark kennedy of the francs a
year also from switzerland
they have with the partnership we can
brought out the limited series
it took almost an hour
where i sold all the tours but of
course i also have  made in the
west by saying everyone can
wear the watch that exists  again
, it's not a problem for me what costs,
and that's how you manage, of course, that
people say it's nice if we
go out now and people
ask, do you like the toilet optically, they
're clear, yes, why don't you buy alex
, I can always sell it there
I have my money safe and there you have to
attack and you have to somehow
create something like fps
clocks or something like that on a small scale I know
the quantities are different but that
you somehow
do a few test pilots where they say
we’ll do it  a limited series and
afterwards just act like that with
this right of repurchase and just make
everything easy and that yes but i
find a good brand so a great
partner so if i am i then he
had to please the evening well i think i
had then we have god  thank you for the
chance we have to look at them and if he has one
or two times i won't be in top shape and before that
i really
didn't want to do much different from the clock  it entered but
please tell me so mechanical watches so
now we're here with you digital
marketing
what do you want with
that I've never worn it so
I just didn't wear a watch at all I was
n't happy of course noticing that
and but was just really
awakened as  who have now
got in touch the person we think that you
are doing is cool and maybe
working and then i somehow
noticed and what do they have to
do then i like that well in
the end it is also his joy
passion and who does the living
and now i've had the chance
to visit the team from cio down
there and also the mechanics and that
's how there is a video is
true they have put the
passion into our
podcast or festivals into
watches and  then when things just look
cool have a tradition and now I'm not even
curious how it will be perceived
that you are my friends now  en say if
I now with the circulation many will probably notice the
same
but I find it very
young is also strange that in
today's digital world these
mechanical timepieces are so
popular absolutely the first
adventure explained in the end is of course
just how  otherwise in the length so that's
there's a lot of message in it
and people don't really care much about the
mechanics now they just want what
message the brand gives the model and
son lives there's one thing you should
n't forget that's something that's happened to
you too  said in another interview the question
is
how will it work in the future there
is still potential there is new
customers we can see that very well with
vintage cars i am talking about
expensive vintage cars that we now have
five from 500,000 euros this generation
or these collectors will die  more or
less from that means today there is
car sharing this status of a
car is no longer s  o high but
it looks completely different with watches i notice
again and again that my main target group is
actually between 18 and 30 years old,
i.e. that the people who
consume my product and
you have to say that this whole
machine of success works has been linked to
this  product very very good and right
but right now don't want a very
cheap one
yes what is there or pgp attracts skeleton
double balance so here you work
with a resonance principle so
you have two hearts in the watch that
beat each other  and
this is supposed to achieve greater
accuracy the whole thing is
irritating so you can look through it and it’s
really great but we’re talking about it with the
preliminary talk savers but
you have around 52,000 point yes so
list prices are not around 60 a
bit more 63,000  it costs 63,000
euros in the shop and the market price is currently around 250c but we will still sell this watch for
300 mar  ke cracks the
researchers and how do you get
this watch so because why does
someone give you another one for 63 if he
knows you can turn around in a
school has for such a watch so you have to
pay more than 200 so that's it
now it's such a thing that
to get it you have to
pay a lot of money but there are
always people who would like to
walk around and have something new where is
this specific one i have here
from the city of hamburg  but
we have exactly from julian's and
he called her and then you have that
too we had yes he called me
and said that a private
person would like to sell it or if i'm
interested i'll say clearly and then
you're there  So I paid 200
and now you know but if you
wanted to get rid of them you could make 50,000
euros if you don't currently
I would keep them for a moment what you
wear yourself tra  gene not
but this watch because of the currently so
there is an anniversary which is very close now
the rookie will be 50 years old
and a lot will happen from then
we expect until the summer with how
many gates does it have so that yes so
market  so the company is my company
so technically seen that all the
company all ears but so
privately owned i would say otherwise so
the now really which i
'm not selling are about 15
maybe 15 and then led into the
company  we have i
mean we have just over 400 400
rostock yes that means you then have a
trading turnover of millions a year of course
we have now the are 30
million have not made it
is less two brazen or almost
have  but already to say what the company
with 30 million turnover that's really
big that's a medium-sized company
already respect so thank you yes well that
's my personal preference  partnership the son but
we have a very
discreet you know from the podcast here
then of course also stay on average
10 20
yes we basically have so i do
n’t know the exact numbers now so i
think i’m there now that’s that
i really know  not but i would always
say we have about ten percent good but
it's then it's as good as
most don't know about the customer so
i can i live my dream if you
i deal with
clocks buffers and all that day in and day out  there is
nothing nicer than that i'm living
my dream and you meet a whole
bunch of crazy people than when you
look who she is at the customer it's
somehow part public let's say
a few examples because there are also
followed I took part in it so i have  now
hamburg because gangster rappers in
europe have a few names
so this one there was again it
was very nice i got to know them i think
two or three times about
everyday issues  that they are in the tram
de then of course in montana black
you know that too is one of the biggest
twitch great i think fifth place
worldwide
then there are a lot of musicians we have them with us
yes and he has been
in the fashion business for a very long time too  it's
also a lot of fun
janitor said that games are also exactly the fashion
let's kick your teeth because I'm
more exactly also really nice
people and so easy each of the
athletes footballers football it's difficult
difficult footballers I don't want to say
but because  soccer is always such a
hot topic soccer players usually
don't want to pay that much now
you said that but when it comes to
soccer players i don't know too
much about soccer and i'll tell you
soccer is difficult so musicians and
actors look  So in principle
the younger generation already -influenza
heavy what you can also see on youtube etc.
you there we really have there I have
sc  hon many many people and
let's also say when he how others took
it you can say what digital
business company or so clear so
I that I both with the about the the
people I've now named
about it now have videos
device but you  you can be
sure the most successful entrepreneurs in
germany the times the
most i have had the least
interest in where there are people who
don't enjoy it at all of course but
otherwise you always cross paths
but it's difficult to name names
because I don't have any videos with which I
don't know if I can say that and so there were
now big names in the USA too,
so also as a result of this social media
kinesiologist paul also herde
producer michael is also someone who is
such a dazzling figure mike
magic to be that  who we also had
in the podcast together with whom we met
in dubai.
america offers great opportunities
and you have to  saying that this culture for
luxury
watches hasn't developed among the younger generation in america
so it's now when you look at logan
portland instead of because i have two three watches well
i mean when we
look at the montana black collection well
i mean that's yes  our 10 times
10 times like this and that's why it's the same for
me that just to
say okay maybe we can
create something great there and
somehow it told
me at some point in the next few weeks and
then I want to
can try to set up a camp in the length he exactly likes
the worldwide at the end you are
i have to drink now from this one
cook in dubai who makes this case is it
this gold state what is it called then
normal that red exactly
what is his name it
should be yes it is unbelievable  what
the power for meat or cooking are you doing
now at the end of the world leading a
good who has the has the product
sales small so we have different
b  We have America and
also Dubai as a location that is
strategically very important to me,
just Asia here and there and
then we also want to do a small
business in a hotel,
we've made a bit of progress there,
but that's it now  it all
always sounds so huge in the end
you just have to do it and you just
have to go about it without thinking and say i
want to open it now and then it
will work out so the
administrative will come we will have
no maintenance costs we have
with that i would like to say you can
create all that such a global network
and where do you have your warehouse because now you have
a high security
situation have different safe deposit boxes at the
banks and there things are easy to
do that’s why we are an online
trade so i don’t have to do them  have at
home or in the office if we have a
watch or let's say if it's
sold now then we have  r our
security and she drives to
pick up the things the bremen cif partners will be
sent and changed and sent
because it is not normal by because they are not
there are a few and companies and
it is surprising but there are no
limits as far as the insurance
value is concerned  I would say from
up to 10,000 euros then there is up to
25,000 euros and then from 25,000 euros there
is then again up to 60,000 euros and then
beyond that
there is shipping again and that's how you work with
changes and what role does it play for you
have a social media manager has
himself or already have me today people
in the office encouragement also coming soon after
market give i already saw in the
story he is on his way to hamburg
that means there are people in the
company who are following something
but you probably don't do all of them now
logically i call a customer
it's not a product is in you t
a t shirt what you say about instagram or
youtube post so how does the
smithy work for you so first of all it is of
course my passion thank god it
is not work for me because i
post every day no matter when there is never
a break but we also
sell other products but the best
fans of the  world we have excellent
nespresso we have different things
start with a
fashion brand now let me tell you my mother she used to be the CEO
of
stada s.oliver and she was basically
at the home world cup now we have
created something great  has
a completely different basis than what
you know now, from which we also make
other products that are now
more affordable, but of
course the focus is still on the
idea of luxury, of course, in propo
tion, they are the most expensive products that we br
ng to the market  and social
media
simply
conveys the whole thing in real time and that's
what you do so i  ch mean it came
here too a huge one you can turn a hand
this and immediately in the conversation i
will so cell phone out is objective there
has and is a way to do but
now you can see a bit so clearly
you can follow anyway so marc
gebauer is called  you come on everyone then the
website also by the way marc gebauer
point yes
but what a profile neurosis or
germany ghana so the hugo boss
so very successful examples
fashion area the company so count the
you yourself so that
but what shows what you look forward to
we actually show everything  so we
have a wide variety of projects
far away from all this
consumption we also have my heart burning
for
de appearing this is an an
organization for where we are building wells in
africa for example a large
large part we were just at the well in
senegal  opens what
we previously collected through the community
now have an orphanage sol for this year
che content you can see because
you can see me on the plane me how
i do everything o'clock in review and yes that
's how the content is actually i
try what is what is the best
clicked on youtube
the best is i think guess with montana
black prices yes
price and who knew advice so I have to
tvg guess it so these are
shrink-wrapped video games that cost around 50 euros
and he then had to guess the watch price
and when I think it was me
even if it wasn’t I just say
ok ok and that  you've already expanded a
range a bit so it's
in the center but you also make
your own water at forster
3 so the fourth air is coming
out have brought three of their own funds onto the
market the
manufacturers so i'd say one of the
best  is
probably
not familiar with corporate designs but that is such a luxury
that the best couple market and
the person who works for this
company and the  mixed oils
so
that one also works for me and
created my performance and
we are also breaking new ground there,
so I brought 1 with me too, that's
a problem, it's completely out of the question, these
limits that we break with it are
crazy, so we have scented oil shares
will i have to give one now which is
the best-selling
we have but also others that just fit for
two or three days the customers
schrems that can't be endured
and yes that's the way you i
realize myself there so it's
in the center now  not that the
commercial success but the couple of
fans that i bring out they had
to please me such the last
performance for brought out that
you can't really think of at the beginning because
the dosage was maybe a bit too
heavy but that my way i just like it
so and i'll just make you
something for me the product so
perforce we have coffee we have and then now
this the brand ge  ber and gebauer for
fashion where we are already so into this
classic conservative
men's fashion and accessories is serious
and now she also wears for lena so
that from the italian manufactory with
25 tailors is a family that has known for a
very long time and will be
very  a lot
[laughter]
logically now 20 30 or
how many suits hanging in the closet 100
100 it's not but i think 70 or
so you have there are any
dates that he was without being attached
is
so i have i have i have two
jogging suits  but only now
so I started jogging twice even but because of
that I'm always I'm always like that
for example jeans I sometimes don't have any jeans at all
I maybe have so I was
determined I did engines twice last year
if that wasn't mine at all
I'm always  always
and now in the usa there you have
some contact points immediately
there you know where to go there
you can already le  ute watch industry
worldwide also small if you now go into
this top then there are not
that many dealers and you can then easily connect yourself in
the end i have
to say my target customer is
not the watch market so i
want to reach the general public and
that’s why  I do
n't necessarily need other dealers now, what
I have to do is good content. I
have to do something
let's say the slightly older
customers that's not my
goal, however, i would like young people,
you young people, who are interested
in the product
and simply find out about it themselves from the start
, i don't have to explain anything to my customers, so they
know  about the videos we continue
anyway more than the normal ones if i
can i can me
still remember how we stood in the shop for my old employer back then like i did back
then and then we had conversations like yes
why is the watch traded at the
list price the band i can well
i'm happy to explain it but
basically if you now if  now
someone comes in he wants to buy this watch
and i say the ecos 40,000 euros
he says but the watch costs 12 in the shop i
say yes that's just the list is
also dubious and how can that be
?  we don't do any advertising either
the only advertising we do is
via instagram youtube we don't have
google ads we don't have anything like that we
only attract the people who know me
if i
could hand over 1000 euros now and you would
because purely in the watch market, so to
speak, the question about stocks I was very
precise, so it could then be found fold yes,
nowhere else can you
earn as much money as never before  really but why
don't you do that why don't you
really let financiers
transfer you millions or more
and involve them and how sensible and says
okay I know so much about this I
have such opportunities I'll go in with
leverage and not with my own  money
and say somehow i understand
my own money plus that you your
people and therefore more in total there are
many there are many examples of companies
that have given up shares
but one thing can not only
say in my life i fill the fridge with
fridges full of me  can no longer go on
vacation i can no longer
drive a car i can no longer so why
am i doing this now only because of
the money we are growing well enough
and i don’t want to be talked into
saying that investments are
partnerships that doesn’t mean there are
always only one captain on the ship
but it means you do
n't want any money for a people
inv  estiere so we have
a large part of our
business concept is this portfolio
management that means you come to us
and say i don't have the
immense idea right now i just want to
invest that and the sum that starts so to
say but at 250,000 euros you can do
something meaningful  mix them together
and then we build a portfolio from the
different watches, which means you have
an unhealthy substructure of certain
rolex models but not the current ones either, it doesn't
matter anyway
and then you can just mix things in
there, we'll do that  but that
's all real for me people it's a
strange lot of questions these days yes i
don't really need the watches the
watches have to be at your house
then you should be there they can
look at them it's nothing virtual
they have them there for you  and
that's a big part, that means
people who aren't really in the market
now say what they're doing  en
would like to know for what period of time whether this is
now high-risk customers who say
yes I am already ready somehow has
me to buy then of course we always stay in
closer exchange because if
the urls then you set yourself a goal,
for example what you want now in
56,000 euros  do and say okay when
the goal is reached then i'll call you too
, then you have to sell because
the germans always have a habit of
buying it, it doesn't matter whether it's from a
porsche or something else, but
selling and then we'll give advice, of
course, is absolutely top priority  yes they
are the most expensive in the usa where the cheapest
men's model back then was 22
but okay that means you but the watches are
sent to the people
they took home actually because
they don't want to wear them we just want to wear them
as a system but it's
important to me that  in such a digital
world and in such a world where everything is not
real, even with crypto and so on
i want people  having that at
home and also understanding and also being able to see
us and there he counts more
to it i don’t just sell there are a
lot now there are also other
platforms
that are suddenly selling certain things that you
can buy shares and then increase in value
that’s all great  but there
is much much more to this watch alone at one
day just so that
you can take the cheapest watch from me the best-selling one data
is all the model from the 80s
90s i think i get the watch with
a paper that is the certificate and
jura is part of it  much much more it
includes a box, it includes two
booklets, at least for the instructions for
use, then there is one thing,
then there are two more hanging texts
, so I would like to say that there are so
many things that are more important
and you should also take them
with you  take it with you
now, so to speak, in the german scene
watches moderately well on the way he does it
well basement the public money
invest invest something like so
there is somehow
good again how look you should subject
meters and all these virtual
worlds play their role
no idea so I'm now with
this nfp and this and that and the
tenant that I can still see it now
not so the watch brand
nike adidas achieve different looks again years
but watch brands not
so i'm very close to the market for
me only what you get cash now counts
and of course there's a marketplace
and that's okay too but i'm
just like  i say stocks is
not my main topic now
i also say that this is
not my topic now it may be
that a lot is happening and such but that is
not gentlemen the market how big was
your own marketing now, i.e.
your own collection, how made  do you
have then
you have sale of so from the
limited series we now had 33
pieces
the bike not
yes yes and it would have been si  nd now worth more
so we can say right
now what is the question that is yes yes
yes so far no one has arrived on the market
but who knows what will happen in the
future only I would say two more
weeks had
arrived on the market  does that
mean that you get the set up but you have
120 teachers exactly so that offers
such a first indication like that
but because the number of pieces is so
small normally
few of them should appear on the market that means
the people bought them today  still
crying too poor what does a normal
collector have how many watches does he have so
i would say 334 pieces but
so we have people who
work with you now with this big westminster
black has then put like 30-40 at
home yes i know them
I don't have the number in my head right now, but of course
if we now go into the top, if we
now make a normal
portfolio for say two to
300,000 euros then then  there are usually
seven at most, so that means you have to
spend a lot of money, so the watches
have become more expensive in some cases, of course, you have
to pay attention to what you
buy, but yes, the better managed it
would have been exactly or hp offers the
most options  the biggest
increase in value in the last twelve months
company policy top and there you have it
so far well
i'll tell you one thing i've been
busy with it for about half a
year my name is also
blocked the live stream the thing
is when i'm in top shape  although depending
on we look at a video and
say i have time again
we have to then we always go over
to or apg to the instagram page
they don't have that many
commons under instagram and then
we just shoot 100  200
comments including everything
we write because I wanted what I
want is I would like
to go to the factory at that time things like that
look they have a museum like that to break it down so to
speak for my
eyes just the window
to the outside mine cools them a
bit to show where does it come from hey
they also have really crass old models
and such and break them down and then
we bomb them  always and then
they had once and then we
had yes they presented
the black panther at live-streaming events
and before that it
was like that
they presented the new collection like that
and that was just a recorded
thing but  just streamed it on youtube
and i was performing live ok and i
had let's say 2000 viewers
that's ok and then they had
like 7 or something
like that definitely less than ok had to
come now go over it then even
passed over  and of course you know how it is
on the internet everyone just
wrote here like give marc
gebauer today you couldn't read anything more
war  that then blocked
but blocked and now it's the same if
I now make comments on youtube
you always have to somehow
no farmer writes
so quickly deleted yes and otherwise we
are hidden but it's the
French brand so in Switzerland
but has the  french part and
they have a really great cooperation with marvel
and so on and i
should be there one day someday i will be
there i already said was just
there what do you want to do not just in
front of the door
but also board you fly travels
drives through  the world meets people and
a trade watches and other
luxury products just discussed yes exactly and
will now says okay I somehow also want to
put on the
topic of the price range the
250 so that you can do that from I can
then also only under that you can
too  You can only buy it for 50 or 14,
but that's always the question of
what you want to achieve, so we have
such  phone calls and conversations also
that you say okay what do you want
so do you want to build something for the
next three years or do you just want
a watch or something like that is the goal wanted
if you only wear i have many
uniqa you can so you can  don't put them
on the watches are just so there
you should be endangered so they are still
stuck with stickers from the
factory or welded in, for example, that means if
you open it now or
remove the stickers you lose 20 percent in
value it's just an
investment so that  you can
only look at the things and not put them on
and you always have to clarify a bit
what the customer
actually wants do you notice that your business is a
bit coalesced with would we
price bitcoin now or with
shares in general that i am also a lot of
people  so how to make money stuck oh
so
ends up so what i notice is that a lot of
people are switching from so let's say
ha  ben a very high cash picture
or a very high amount of money and
just want to invest that
we have also sold a lot of customers
an apartment now and are stuck that
seniors but now so bitkom so well
I didn’t notice anything so that’s
that I see now  the willingness to spend is not generally
high
and people are willing to invest things
or money,
but that i say now, especially since we have
the empirical values i mean i have since
i got credit from the bürgschaftsbank and kfw a
d it was for f
unding the company and  That was of course
also the case back then, so that the ones
who had to approve it were also a
bit conservative, so
Gebauer has always been so everything in the bubble
and as far as it is possible to get
, then I took three
models from Rolex, three or  but
marina di massa has four thomas models
and has been looking since 19
since 1990 why  price development was and
here everything happened 27 28 when
the crisis was what happened to the watch
prices and i was able to break it down
very clearly sons they have
the solid return every year apart
from other models now of course
blatantly explode but i trade them
now  not so much and then i was able
to read it out and in the end i got the
loan too because you just see
these fears in people too
okay it’s not just a
temporary deal at 2 728 of course
the market is then maybe at seven
to  twelve percent went down briefly
because america has flooded a lot of watches onto the
market but
basically it's relatively
crisis-proof if you stick to certain
rules why why do you think that you
guys are
in prison so what type of
actually not a classic
luxury product with him  it surprised me enormously
but that rolex
buys something like this over the counter rolex close to me
r he had in the video he had a
santos file so that's something with
diamonds it's more like a flash
apps now once led such an appearance
or something but he also has
something more conservative in his collection can
surprise me that but that's the
same in the end  what happens to young people
when you're young and
growing up in today's world and you
look at the most successful people in
the world, then we'll
actually get a clear picture of all of them. mark zuckerberg
maybe not, but otherwise we see
something of
high quality in everyone  watch on your wrist and
then the question is whether
joe biden, for example, had just had
something like that with stalin that's also a
message and if you yourself now have
certain things you've already had with
donald trump it was already constantin
i think patrimoine or historique
was one thing  day date 36 mm very
up-to-date model solid gold from
rolex watches a bit smaller in any case and
if you then stop s  agen okay i
see that with these successful people
and you also want to
somehow reflect the success yourself and then
you say that an expensive watch date 36
millimeters small costs 18,000 euros but
there is still more to it and then
this inner drive is of  many
people higher faster further and then
suddenly you turn around and have a
judge succeed but but let's
not be like that in germany olaf scholz or
politicians in germany there are
n't any
but if you if you now go countries by
character you just asked
putin what has the figures long left us with such
a big complication these
are all things power
these are crass statements wearable
only for 5000 euros for example
now it is the polish there is also he
had it too if we are there other
politicians who have noticed or  so
clearly now in the area of from in the thai
rea or also now saudi
arabia or or also dubai there the t
e  family there are brands
created richard with so they are
there they always have the models on and that triggers
a certain hype
there is a worldwide
there are partners so now at ibc
spoken by james who is still a
real pusher there are  but
the person already more the musician
beautiful also wears eric clapton
nadal than he is an athlete of course
but when we talk about it now
opinion leaders gentleman who trigger
trends e.g. john mayer yes i would just say the daytona
with the green dial rainbow daytona he
has things  triggered that's
really and ed sheeran that's
totally german yours has a
mentally ill collection will be big
complications while of watches the
cost well over a million euros really
really big let's go up the stairs to
his concert yes exactly eric
clapton eric clapton has
lies he has one  value at patek he
goes there for example said i
would like this watch with this number
latt in the color and the
numbers do that 4 1 victory individual
pieces that will come now the
two i like but i would like
pink is informed you say yes ok
but do it
[laughter]
so i know that as a musician but that
the and  i finally had donald trump in my sights
when he is also rolex,
so to speak, then in germany, so to speak, has
n’t dated a huge watch group up to now,
but he already has three, four, five, six
models so that you can meet up immediately, so
if you want to take photos or meet
up, i’ve still met you
what the future will bring but it
means you see or
photos you always have some pictures
or something of the golf course this there are also
instagram pages that only report about it now
celebrity watch potter is
a page that always shows which
celebrities have on their wrists
okay  that you
know for sure you've been attacked before
we've been robbed or mugged
so i'm actually always on the go with security
If I now have
valuables with me in the office I
always have someone with me and
so google voice is someone from
mma who looks after us very well and
therefore
nothing has happened so far
thank you very much an incredible story
and you are open for business so if
now  would i assume to say
that some listeners said i feel like getting some
advice do you also do
counseling anja so we analyze that
is of course everything through e-mail you
have to take a little time you
have to write an e-mail and
then we will deal with it  report the
world of clocks so
slower yes so it's done and
yourself a bit who is that now there
who write that and you will you with everyone
there so in the end I'm not
looking now so of course you have to agree
beforehand what goals the person has if
that  so fits and so and then yes
you get together so if someone
is interested and has fun with this profession and says they
would like something in the rich
then we can have a look
markett marc gebauer punkt com info at
mag geber reached and with c
his mother was
together now
okay he
likes it all right
[applause]
[music]